[Música]
según la oposición venezolana más de
seis millones de personas hicieron parte
de la consulta en rechazo de las
elecciones legislativas del pasado 6 de
diciembre que además pedía la salida del
presidente nicolás maduro sin embargo
existen dudas sobre las cifras de
participación y no se conoce qué
porcentaje de personas estuvo a favor o
en contra
y al límite para el futuro de los
diálogos sobre el break si los
negociadores del reino unido y la unión
europea sostienen una reunión en
bruselas y se espera que el primer
ministro boris johnson y la presidenta
de la comisión europea ursula von der
leyen sostengan una conversación
telefónica este domingo contactamos con
lo triste
alemania endurecen sus medidas
destinadas a frenar el brote de kobe 19
tras una reunión con los líderes
regionales la canciller alemana angela
merkel anunció que desde este 16 de
diciembre y hasta el 10 de enero se
cerraran las escuelas y la mayoría de
los negocios no esenciales
feliz domingo bienvenidos a un nuevo
informativo en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz de acuerdo con la
oposición venezolana más de 6 millones
400 mil personas hicieron parte de la
consulta popular que pedía la salida del
presidente nicolás maduro y rechazaban
los resultados de las elecciones del
pasado 6 de diciembre sin embargo
existen diversas dudas sobre el algunas
cifras no verificadas por observadores
no se sabe si quienes acudieron a las
urnas repitieron su participación de
manera virtual ni cuál es el porcentaje
de quienes votaron a favor o en contra
deslegitimar la validez de las
elecciones del pasado 6 de diciembre ese
fue el objetivo de la consulta popular
impulsada por la oposición venezolana
que terminó con la votación presencial
realizada este sábado a la que acudieron
más de 3.200.000 personas
creo que el gran contraste del día de
hoy es la manifestación de voluntad de
los venezolanos ejerciendo no solamente
el rechazo al fraude no solamente el
rechazo a la declaración o voluntad
férrea de avanzar por la libertad de
venezuela yo creo que lo primero la
existencia de una alternativa
democrática en venezuela mayoritaria y
no solamente mayoritaria sino organizada
desde tempranas horas llegaron los
primeros venezolanos a los 3000 centros
de votación habilitados en diversos
puntos del país
no estamos conformes con la situación
que tenemos en nuestro país por lo menos
algo debemos hacer
que mucha gente ya y ni siquiera al está
parando este tipo de cosas porque ya
está escéptica frente a los resultados
pero algo hay casas
el disidente político leopoldo lópez
también participó en la consulta lo hizo
desde colombia donde permanece en un
intento por lograr movilizar a sus
compatriotas exiliados contra el
gobierno de nicolás maduro por eso hoy
nosotros ratificamos nuestro compromiso
a salir del dicta con salir del dictador
nicolás maduro nicolás maduro no sólo es
un dictador nicolás maduro es un
criminal
nicolás maduro ha cometido crímenes de
lesa humanidad ha hecho violaciones
severas de derechos humanos según el
comité organizador la consulta superó en
participación a los comicios
legislativos convocados por el
oficialismo en poco más de 200.000 votos
se estima que fueron más de 6 millones
466 mil electores los que respondieron a
la consulta lo que equivale al 31 22%
del padrón electoral de la nación
petrolera sin embargo quedan dudas ya
que las cifras no fueron constatadas por
observadores y no hay claridad sobre si
quienes votaron presencialmente también
pudieron sufragar online
hoy es un día decisivo para el break
sheet los negociadores británicos y de
la unión europea llevan a cabo una
reunión con la que buscan salir del
estancamiento y llegar a un acuerdo
antes de que finalice el periodo de
transición de la salida del reino unido-
del bloque comunitario ambas partes
tienen hasta la medianoche para llegar a
un acuerdo aunque es posible que las
conversaciones continúen vencido este
plazo también se espera una conversación
hoy entre el primer ministro británico
boris johnson y la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen en
un nuevo intento de salvar la situación
vamos hasta londres con nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido para ampliar
este tema
luisa muy buenos días que esperar de
esta fecha límite para el futuro de las
negociaciones que tan estancada está
este panorama
buenos días las negociaciones están
estancadas en estos tres puntos
fundamentales el acuerdo está negociado
en su mayoría hace rato hace varios
meses pero estos tres puntos han evitado
que se llegue al acuerdo
recordemos básicamente sobre los
derechos de pesca que se ha convertido
en un símbolo para el primer ministro y
para darles una idea de lo importante y
lo simbólico que resulta es que en el
2016 este fondo de las banderas de los
motivos para el referendo para salir de
la unión europea así que estos líderes
hoy especie la presidenta de la comisión
europea y el primer ministro boris
johnson hablarán sobre el mediodía -hora
local- para tratar de revisar si desde
el miércoles ha habido un avance lo
suficientemente importante que les
permita creer que habrá humo blanco al
final o finalmente no entonces tendrían
que seguir las negociaciones pero no se
sabe hasta cuándo
dado que el 31 de diciembre como
mencionas es la fecha límite y el
acuerdo debe ser ratificado por los
parlamentos tanto británicos como de la
unión europea
se prevé que de no lograr un acuerdo los
diálogos se extiendan en este caso que
sigue luís a
podrían extenderse por supuesto podría
seguir por una semana más o hasta más
allá del 31 de diciembre de este año es
decir seguirían en el 2021 lo que sería
catastrófico para el primer ministro
boris johnson quien fue elegido
recordemos para sacar al reino unido-
definitivamente de la unión europea ahí
la complejidad veremos y boris johnson
decide entonces que es hora de anteponer
sus intereses personales más allá de los
intereses del país así que es una
conversación bien bien importante porque
lo que está en juego es bien complejo no
solamente estaría implicando las dos
economías tanto de la unión europea como
del reino unido- sino una crisis que
podría verse en este país en las
fronteras a lo largo y ancho del canal
de la mancha a partir del primero de
enero porque toda la comida
prácticamente que llega al reino unido-
viene de productos de la unión europea
así que de ahí la complejidad
pues luisa muchísimas gracias por su
informe desde londres nosotros estaremos
al tanto de esta noticia para llevarles
a ustedes toda la actualización y
cambiamos de tema vamos a alemania que
entra en una fase de confinamiento más
estricta debido al aumento de casos de
kobe 19 y de muertes en el país de los
en los últimos días la canciller alemana
angela merkel confirmó que las medidas
vigentes no han sido efectivas a la hora
de controlar las infecciones motivo por
el cual se decidió el cierre de escuelas
y la mayoría de negocios no esenciales a
partir del próximo miércoles y hasta el
10 de enero veamos el informe
alemania ha estado parcialmente
confinada durante las últimas seis
semanas con bares y restaurantes
cerrados algunos lugares han sido
criticados por montar puestos de comida
de temporada para llevar no valgo el
bridge
nadie se hará rico vendiendo 3 o 4
litros de vino caliente por supuesto que
vemos caras nuevas lo importante para
nosotros es mantener el contacto con
nuestra base de clientes y también poder
pagar el alquiler
superbrands
pero los dueños de negocios se enfrentan
ahora a medidas de cierre más estrictas
con las tiendas cerradas a partir de
mediados de la próxima semana y hasta el
10 de enero la canciller angela merkel
dijo que las reglas actuales ya no son
suficientes discuto el endurecimiento de
las restricciones este domingo durante
una videoconferencia con los líderes de
los 16 estados de alemania las
autoridades locales habían acordado un
plan para permitir que el cierre se
suavizará en navidad' pero algunas
regiones han impuesto desde entonces
medidas más duras incluyendo baviera y
el estado suroccidental de
baden-württemberg donde se han
establecido toques de queda nocturnos
alemania fue elogiada internacionalmente
por su éxito en mantener la pandemia
bajo control a principios de este año
pero ha sido golpeada duramente por una
segunda ola del virus con nuevas
infecciones superando hasta en tres
veces el pico de la primavera algunos
ministros advierten que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos se están colapsando
y que el país no puede esperar hasta
después de navidad para actuar
el número de casos confirmados de kobe
19 aumentó en más de 20.000 este domingo
para alcanzar más de 13 millones y casi
22 mil personas han muerto
eeuu se alista para la primera jornada
masiva de vacunación contra el cob y 19
que tendrá lugar a partir de este lunes
el fármaco será distribuido en 14 puntos
del país de acuerdo con el ejército la
campaña se da luego de que la fed
aprobara el uso de emergencia de la
vacuna de las farmacéuticas pfizer y
bayonne tec se prevé que los
trabajadores de la salud sean los
primeros en recibir la dosis seguido de
los adultos mayores
hasta aquí esta emisión de noticias de
france 24 los invitamos a que continúen
con toda nuestra programación
[Música]